it's frustrating you can't find exactly
what you want exactly when you want it
you know it's out there but it's hard to
find and when it comes to research data
even if you do find it how exactly do
you understand it
scientific data is an innovative new way
of making data visible to and reusable
for the entire scientific community
we're interested in not just the results
but how you get there we publish data
descriptors that help you understand the
data publication makes it possible to
credit and cite data so that your work
has the maximum possible impact it can a
reliable peer review process makes it
easier to confidently reuse data share
knowledge and accelerate discovery
a unique open access platform makes data
easier to find and easier to understand
we categorize and curate the data
descriptor to increase your data's
impact we believe in improving the way
that data is managed shared and
interpreted we believe in open science
in the scientific community because we
believe that data sharing and reuse
speeds the scientific process and
facilitates discovery scientific data
helping you publish discover and reuse
research data
you